I feel like someone's feelings or
expressed feelings about someone like
Jordan Peterson is a good indicator of
whether or not they're a sentient being
or an NPC I'm being somewhat facetious
but what I mean is
a rational person will say either I'm
not familiar I I've heard about Jordan
Peterson but I've not listened to him
before so I have no real strong opinions
or they'll say something rational like
you know I've listened to him I'm not a
big fan of some of the points he made
about religion I don't agree with or
they'll say I'm a big fan of the things
he said because
you know they said otherwise any one of
those responses indicates a thinking
person who's like you know let me try
and figure this out but the people who
are like he's an incel hero evil
alt-right whatever they clearly haven't
done any groundwork to understanding or
listening to anything that he has to say
so if you're trying to figure out if
someone is a Discerning individual or
let's just say an NPC in the in the
colloquial sense you can ask them about
Jordan Peterson